THEY DON'T OPPOSE HATRED.
THEY ARE ENCOURAGING HATRED
OBVIOUSLY.
LET'S STOP LYING ABOUT THAT.
WELL COMEDIAN AND PODCAST HOST
ADAM KROLL ONE OF THE MOST
DEFENDERS OF ACTUAL FREE SPEECH
LEFT IN AMERICA.
HE IS NOT ONLY FAMOUS HOST BUT
AN AMAZING CAR RACING FAN AND
PARTICIPANT.
WE WERE IN L.A. LAST WEEK AND
DECIDED TO GO OVER TO HIS RACE
CAR GARAGE AND TALK TO HIM
BECAUSE WE COULDN'T RESIST
BECAUSE IT'S AMAZING.
HERE IS HOW THE CONVERSATION
RESULTED.
>> Tucker: YOU'VE BEEN ON THE
ROAD FOR THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS
TALKING ABOUT FREE SPEECH.
I KNOW YOUR VIEWS ON IT.
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO CONVINCE
THE AUDIENCE ESPECIALLY YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT FREE SPEECH MATTERS?
ARE THEY ON YOUR SIDE, DO YOU
THINK?
>> Adam: I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
CONVINCE MY AUDIENCE THAT FREE
SPEECH MATTERS.
AND I THINK THE PENDULUM IS
STARTING TO SWING BACK A LITTLE
BIT, YOU KNOW, WE HAD A
SATURATION LEVEL.
I SORT OF BELIEF AS HUMAN BEINGS
WE WORK THIS WAY.
I BELIEVE THAT IN THE LATE 80s
80s, HAIR BANDS AND BIG GUYS
WEARING FONTS AND SPANDEX AND
AQUA NET, EYELINER AND
EVERYTHING ELSE AND THAT GAVE
WAY TO GRUNGE MUSIC.
KURT COBAIN, TATTERED SHIRTS,
NOBODY CARED, RIGHT?
SO WHAT COULD BE FURTHER AWAY
FROM HAIR BANDS, GRUNGE MUSIC.
THAT IS WHAT CAME NEXT.
SO I'M STARTING TO WONDER IF IT
IS SWINGING BACK.
I THINK THE INSANITY OF THE WOKE
FOLKS OUT THERE HAVE FORCED SAIN
PEOPLE TO PUSH BACK AND MAY BE
GOING FROM THE HAIR BAND TO THE
GRUNGE MOVEMENT.
>> Tucker: HAS THE WOKE PEOPLE
PUSHED BACK AGAINST YOU?
>> Adam: THE WOKE PEOPLE WILL
PUSH BACK AGAINST ANYBODY.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU DON'T SEEM
BOTHERED.
YOU ARE THE ONE PERSON WHO SEEMS
TOTALLY DISINTERESTED AND
BOTHERED BY THEIR ATTACKS.
>> Adam: I KNOW WHAT'S IN MY
HEART AND I HATE THAT STATEMENT,
BUT I KNOW WHO I AM.
YOU CAN'T CONVINCE ME THAT HATE
ASEXUAL PRO -- HATE A PERSON,
YOU COULDN'T CONVINCE ME COME I
HATED A NEIGHBOR OR A FRIEND OR
HISPANIC, BLACKS.
YOU CAN'T BESTOW THAT UP ON ME.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS INSIDE
ME, AND I'M AWARE OF IT AND I
KNOW I DON'T.
SO YOU CAN'T CONVINCE ME OF
THAT.
>> Tucker: SO YOU'RE NOT
AFRAID BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY ARE SAYING IS A LIE?
>> Adam: YEAH, AND I'M AN
ATHEIST AND I REALLY DON'T CARE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY I'M GOING
TO GO RACE ONE OF THESE CARS
CHEMICAL RANCH ON SOMETHING,
BUILD ON SOMETHING AND EAT
DINNER WITH MY KIDS AND WIFE.
THERE IS KIND OF A FREEDOM AND
NOT CARING.
THERE IS A REAL FREEDOM IN NOT
CARING.
>> Tucker: WHY DON'T MORE
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THAT?
>> Adam: I THINK THERE IS
VANITY.
AND I THINK EVERYBODY IS WIRED
TO BE A LITTLE BIT NARCISSISTIC
AND NO ONE WANTS TO GO ONLINE
AND READ BAD THINGS ABOUT
THEMSELVES.
NOBODY WANTS TO READ UNTRUTHS OR
AN ACCURATE -- INACCURATE THINGS
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
AND SO WE ARE WIRED TO
ALLEVIATE.
AND SO I'VE NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT
IT THIS WAY BUT YOUR EGO WHEN
YOUR ANKLE IS SORE, YOU ARE
WIRED TO STAY OFF YOUR ANKLE,
LIKE LESS WEIGHT, HOP, LEAN THIS
WAY.
YOU GO ON TWITTER AND YOU READ A
BUNCH OF HORRIBLE THINGS ABOUT
YOURSELF, YOU ARE WIRED TO
ALLEVIATE.
YOU ARE NOT WIRED TO PUT WEIGHT
ON A ROLLED ANKLE.
YOU ARE WIRED TO SAY OH, PEOPLE
ARE SAYING XYZ ABOUT ME ON
TWITTER.
LET'S FIX THAT AND THE FIX IS
APOLOGIZING, WALKING -- WALKING
STATEMENTS BACK TO GET IT TO GO
AWAY.
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN THE TRUTH.
I'M NOT INTERESTED WHAT THE
HISTORY BOOKS SAY.
MY ANKLE HURTS AND I WANT TO GET
THE WEIGHT OFF A BIT
IMMEDIATELY.
>> Tucker: SO YOU WALKING THIS
STUFF BACK AND YOU APOLOGIZING,L
STUFF BACK AND YOU APOLOGIZING,K
STUFF BACK AND YOU APOLOGIZING,E
STUFF BACK AND YOU APOLOGIZING,Y
STUFF BACK AND YOU APOLOGIZING,U
KOWTOWING TO THESE PEOPLE AS A
WAY TO GET THE WEIGHT, IT'S LIKE
A CRUTCH AND I CAN GET THE
WEIGHT OFF OF THIS AND IT WILL
GO AWAY.
AND I DON'T CARE WHAT THE DOCTOR
ORTHOPEDIC SAYS ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: RIGHT NOW IT HURTS
AND I WANTED TO GO AWAY.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU DON'T PLAY
THAT GAME AND THEREFORE YOU
DON'T BOTHER YOU.
AND THAT IS A MODEL FOR THE REST
OF US.
IF EVERYBODY HAD THAT ATTITUDE,
I DON'T CARE I JUST WANT TO
WRENCH ON MY CAR SO I DON'T HAVE
TO DEAL WITH MY KIDS AND THEY
WILL HAVE NO POWER.
>> Adam: THEY ARE NOT IN THE
BUSINESS OF BANGING THEIR HEAD
AGAINST THE WALL.
THEY ARE IN THE BUSINESS OF
MOWING YOU DOWN AND MOVING ONTO
THE NEXT SUBJECT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
THEY ARE IMMEDIATE GRATIFICATION
CREW.
LET'S REMEMBER THESE ARE KIDS I
GOT EVERYTHING THEY WANTED
IMMEDIATELY.
IF YOU DON'T GIVE THEM IMMEDIATE
GRATIFICATION, THEY ARE OFF YOU
IN TWO DAYS.
THIS IS NOT A LONG SLAUGHTER
OVER MONTHS AND YEARS.
YOU GIVE ME WHAT I WANT RIGHT
NOW WHICH IS AN APOLOGY OR YOU
CAN GET FIRED FROM YOUR JOB OR
WHATEVER THAT IS.
YOU COULD BE HUMILIATED.
YOU COULD BE CONTRITE.
IF YOU DON'T GIVE AN ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY, THEY IMMEDIATELY
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT VICTIM.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE TO BE A TO
GIVE AND TO UNREASONABLE
DEMANDS, WOULDN'T YOU?
>> Adam: I THINK SO.
BUT YOU THINK ABOUT ALL THE
POLITICIANS AND ALL OF THE
NEWSCASTERS AND VOICES OUT
THERE.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE ONES THAT
SORT OF WEATHERED THE STORM AND
JUST PUT THEIR HEAD DOWN AND
SAID, NO APOLOGY.
THEY IMMEDIATELY PACK UP AND GO
FIND ANOTHER VICTIM.
OR SOMEBODY TO TURN INTO A
VICTIM.
AND IF IT IS CLEAR THAT THERE IS
NOTHING HERE FOR YOU, IF THEY
RING YOU LIKE A BAR OREGANO
TEARS COME OUT, THEY MOVE ON
BECAUSE THEY WANT A BUCKET OF
TEARS.
THEY WANT A BUCKET OF TEARS AND
THEY RING AND THEY RING AND